fox news alert a monumental day in
america with the supreme court
overturning roe versus wade i'm dana
perrino along with katie pavlich jessica
tarlov martha mccallum and one lucky guy
greg gutfeld five o'clock in new york
city and this is the five
[Music]
the supreme court sending the issue of
abortion back to the states the historic
decision overturning the 50-year-old
ruling on roe v wade which guaranteed
women the right to an abortion
the federal right to an abortion the
move already having significant
political social and cultural
implications both sides of the debate
gathering all day outside the high court
as america absorbs the news president
biden coming out today attacking the
decision
it's a sad day for the court and for the
country now with rogue on
let's be very clear
the health and life of women in this
nation
are now at risk it was three justices
named by one president donald trump
were the core of today's decision to
upend the scales of justice and
eliminate a fundamental right
for women in this country it's a
realization of an extreme ideology and a
tragic error by the supreme court in my
view but this decision
must not be the final word
for more let's go to our chief legal
correspondent shannon bream and shannon
we were on television this morning
together on america's newsroom as the
news broke and you were so able to
quickly read the decision discern it but
i'm wondering now just several hours
later how it's all settled in for you
yeah a couple things interesting that
this morning dana normally what happens
with the supreme court opinion we have
all that sound and fury in the morning
and then after the decision kind of
settles in uh the groups will go away
but we've got the opposite here today
more and more people are showing up here
at the court they are chanting they are
vowing this is not going to be the end
it's interesting to hear a president of
the united states say this can't be the
final word saying this to the judicial
branch to the independent branch from
him but for now the supreme court is the
final word on this the left has been
putting this in terms of taking away a
constitutional right but what the wright
has argued and what the court said today
is there was never a constitutional
right to an abortion under roe people
across the political spectrum had
worried that it had weak underpinnings
we talked about this justice ruth bader
ginsburg was among those who worried
that it was susceptible and vulnerable
to challenge exactly like what we've
seen happen play out here today now the
president and the speaker of the house
have also made comments to the effect
that
you've got to get to the polls of course
it's smart for them to harness this
politically but they're saying things
like contraception and same-sex marriage
are now going to be a threat and they're
pointing to a line in a concurrence from
justice thomas but what he said if you
go and read that is he says there is
nothing in this opinion today this
abortion opinion that has anything to do
with those rights it will not impact
them it should not but he does go on to
say that he thinks the court should
engage in a different kind of process
for other cases moving forward and he
does mention re-examining the
substantive due process rights in cases
like obergefell which is the one that
made same-sex marriage legal in all 50
states so everybody that signed on to
this opinion today agrees there is no
threat there should be no threat let me
read something from justice alito to
those other key opinions he says we have
stated unequivocally that nothing in
this opinion should be understood to
cast out on precedents that do not
concern abortion we have also explained
what is why that is so rights regarding
contraception and same-sex relationships
are inherently different from the right
to abortion because the latter as we
have stressed uniquely involves what row
and casey termed potential life it is
hard to see how we could be clearer so
while the left will continue to try to
make hay out of that the court has been
very clear those rights will not be
under attack because of this particular
decision today dana janet preem thank
you i know you've done incredible work
today and have a lot cut out for you the
rest of the weekend thank you
martha one of the things that going into
this is about 65 percent of americans
mistakenly believe that roe being
overturned means that it was just banned
all across the country and what we're
trying to explain to people is that this
sends the decisions back to the states
now in some states like in new york you
might want to have any changes but in
other states like perhaps missouri for
example or even texas you will have
significant changes
that's exactly right and i'm amazed by
how many people you know well a lot of
us and certainly shannon spend a lot of
time focused on the way that the
justices approach these sort of
decisions but this it doesn't just they
don't wake up one morning and say you
know what we have a majority in the
court right now we sort of are
like-minded on this why don't we
overturn roe v wade it's not like that
they had a case that came before them
mississippi had implemented a 15-week
ban which is a shorter ban than was
really enshrined in roe v wade so that
it bubbled all the way up to the court
and then they have to make this decision
on it and
more than half the states look like they
will maintain
their abortion rights and it looks like
about half of them will either ban or
will have six week or 15 week bans
you know which is a considerable period
of time it's interesting in our polling
uh 54
of those say that they think it's right
to ban
after 15 weeks which is close to four
months of pregnancy they say that seems
like a reasonable measure a reasonable
point so i think when you really get
behind this you realize that it is um
going to be nuanced there will certainly
be places in the country where it's more
difficult to get an abortion but i would
also point out one thing and that is
that we have seen really a complete
change in abortion in this country more
than half or as many as 60 percent of
abortions in the country are done by by
prescription pill that comes in the mail
they're not done at clinics across the
country that's one of the reasons that
you've seen clinics shutting down it's
not just opposition to abortion it's
also that they are their business is
shrinking and i think a lot of people
would say that that's a good thing
a good development in all of this we
remember when bill clinton said he
wanted to see abortion that was safe and
legal and rare uh that's not the kind of
voices that we're hearing on the other
side of this debate right now this um
decision has long been derided jessica
as one that was not a good
not a decision well made and an argument
well made and even
the late justice ruth bader ginsburg
said that and yet even though this uh
decision had leaked in a memo about 55
days ago
it still can be shocking for some that
it turned out the way that it did
absolutely i was definitely one of those
people who knew it was coming and i was
on um with you guys talking about it the
day that the opinion got leaked and i
felt
the
the pain of it you know not just for
myself but for millions of women across
the country who um depend on
safe and legal access to abortion and to
women's health care more generally and
yes ruth bader ginsburg had a problem
with the opinion she did not have a
problem with the right to abortion the
original case was a privacy case it was
decided seven to two and the chief
justice was appointed by a republican
and i think that that is something that
has gotten lost in the conversation
today that people are not using the
privacy word enough here and i do firmly
believe that if this
was a case if if men were the people
that were carrying the children
that this would never have happened and
i think that women are being put in a
terrible position the statistics are
very clear about who this is going to
affect the most it's women who earn less
it's predominantly women of color
there is a laxness
to
the idea that it's just easy to cross
state lines to just go get an abortion
it's no big deal i mean today in west
virginia and arkansas immediately all
abortions that were scheduled for today
moving forward were canceled
and abortions are not just for women
that got pregnant by accident because
they slept with the wrong guy it's for
medical reasons
protecting the life of the mother some
of these states
are going to have no exceptions for rape
or incest and i find it very hard to
believe for the conservatives on tv i
saw ted cruz on earlier you know touting
the ruling that if one of ted cruz's
daughters got pregnant because she was
raped or god forbid a you know an uncle
or someone got her pregnant that he
wouldn't do everything in his power to
make sure that his daughter didn't have
to carry that baby to term the hypocrisy
is
beyond comprehension here uh republican
women get pregnant too and i'm not
saying we can't have a conversation
about 15 weeks or 20 weeks i know a lot
of people who are pro-choice have
numbers like that but when this goes
back to states 13 of which have trigger
laws that are going to go into effect
right away that means that at six weeks
when they don't even have you come in
for a heartbeat appointment yet at that
point uh women are putting in an
incredibly unfair position and i was on
with martha earlier for a discussion
about this and we were talking about
what gorsuch and kavanaugh had said and
susan collins and joe manchin have both
released statements saying that they
were misled quote from justice gorsuch i
accept the law of the land roe v wade
was law of the land he deceived the
senators and he deceived the american
people kavanaugh as well and there's
some language from amy coney barrett
that i would add to that okay you know
jonathan turley did push back pretty
hard on that but justices
but katie i'll go to you so there are a
lot of women that actually support this
decision yes as well a lot of women who
have been pro-life and they have fought
for this uh ruling to be overturned and
for the decisions to be sent back to the
states right as it is now yeah the
number of pro-life organizations in fact
i think almost all of them are run by
women the susan b anthony list the march
for life all run by women and the
narrative is that women disagree with
this decision that's not true
this for pro-life activists today is a
huge victory they've been working on for
five decades this is something they
believe is far overdue that an injustice
against millions of innocent lives
inside the womb has been corrected at a
federal level but the fact is that this
is now being sent back to the states
it's actually expanded democracy by
allowing 50 state legislatures to debate
this to be accountable to the people in
their states about what they want to do
um and the fight for the pro-life
activists and the pro-abortion activists
isn't over they're going to have to
convince the people in their state that
an abortion ban uh with no exceptions
with exceptions maybe 15 weeks like
we're about to see in virginia under
republican governor glenn younkin that
that is politically feasible and
something that the people who live in
that state actually want i mean the
tenth amendment says anything that is
not in the constitution
specifically is sent back to the states
and the people who live in those states
and that is what has happened today and
also when it comes to how we got to this
moment she actually blamed democrats for
this in a way
ruth bader ginsburg didn't want to
retire she could have retired early that
could have been a democratic seat put
there hillary clinton lost to donald
trump after taking advantage and taking
for granted the campaign not working as
hard as she could have and harry reid
who was a senate majority leader changed
the rules on the filibuster so it was
easier to confirm supreme court justices
so
for pro-life activists this is a huge
moment in american history but it's not
over you know this will continue at the
state level and pro-life groups led by
women will continue to fight it in their
principle there there was one other
woman who mentioned we just want to play
this for you this is alexandria
ocasio-cortez this is her take today
watch
what the supreme court just did is that
they chose to
endanger
the lives of all women
and all burdened people in this country
um but not only that they've chosen to
strip
rights from men too
all birthing people yes right we mustn't
forget the birthing people
they are now the most important people
on the planet because they're being
included everything in everything but i
think the real injustice today is uh
that i am the only male on this panel
and i'm still not in the center seat
if you think about that what what is
that what what is that uh
it's it's it's in all seriousness this
is as bad as the nick trades last night
i don't know if you guys saw that a
little sports humor because i'm the dude
here one lucky guy i think there's a um
i'll be short because i'm only the only
guy here even though my opinion matters
more than all of you combined
there's an obvious one-sentence
explanation for both rulings the guns
guns are in the constitution abortion
isn't
let the states figure it out i know that
sounds harsh but that's actually
inarguable it's not in the constitution
i do feel bad for liberals in the media
i think someone should check in on on
the view uh between the gun ruling and
this one we should remove all sharp
objects from their set perhaps their
shoelaces but i think you can have three
or four different opinions in your head
for example you could admit that roe v
wade was a deeply flawed ruling and not
only is it overturned it's ending that's
the important thing but you could also
say hell it's been around for 50 years
when something's been around for 50
years why don't you just let it be all
right we're already used to it we don't
want to upset the apple cart but the
fact is
we've upset a lot of apple carts that we
don't like there have been things that
have been around for hundreds of years
that we changed we fought a war over
something okay
uh you can be i don't know you could be
confident
even if you're pro-choice you could be
confident that this will be settled
state by state and it might even life
will even go on for some unborn children
which will be really really nice if you
don't like covet regulations you can
vote in new politicians or you can move
to florida
if you don't like your abortion
regulations you could elect new leaders
or you can move to california or new
york so that is how stuff works here
right and uh i also think the decision
it was a a great rebuke to the leakers i
believe it was leaked by the dems
because it went to politico it didn't go
to like national review or fox news and
that was with the express purpose of
foreshadowing liberal outrage that would
intimidate and influence the court and
it just
it didn't happen the court gave them the
ruling show that you can't scare the
court and i think that's great it's just
too bad that biden uh doesn't seem
interested in dissuading any of the
hysteria that's going on right now and
just that last i've heard it a couple
times like what if men could get
pregnant
you can't prove it i mean wait aren't
men getting pregnant birthing people
yeah birthing people so we should we
should defer to them jessica we should
defer to them birthing people get the
final say in everything i think i think
you do know what i meant about that
but it's that kind of hypothetical
cliche that i always hear and it's like
you know you know well we've been
fighting wars forever that was our
abortion
i would argue that it actually makes men
more accountable for their behavior and
that they actually have to be
accountable for what they do
all right up next democrats telling
people to get into the streets as
america braces for potential violence
over this supreme court abortion ruling
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else